as has been a prophecy proof of prophet
Muhammad is other prophecies but to add
to the proof of him being the last and
final messenger sent to mankind with the
difference being he said tens of
statements about these people other
prophecies may be one statement one
incident so this one because of the
danger of these people he had multiple
absolutely because it is a revelation
from Allah what he says yes so when he
said it he spoke about this group has
been some of the most dangerous groups
for Muslims they kill Muslims
that's what he says they kill Muslims
they don't spare anybody who is fearful
of Allah someone who is a good believer
they don't spare them they lie they
deceive they do everything today that
Islam prohibits under the name of Islam
I mean is there any any Islamic law that
uh things that are not allowed for
Muslims that they didn't do man every
day you hear a new thing that Islam
forbids you can't do that you know that
pilot
um okay that guy was his plane was shut
down so they they burned him alive
I had a meeting with one of the security
agents in Jordan and he was asking me
about I said listen burning anybody
alive is not allowed because the prophet
of Allah Muhammad himself
no one burns with fire except the
creator of the fire
so only Allah takes people to Hell Fire
we can't do that now he says whatever I
said I don't need to denounce it because
burning somebody like this is absolutely
unacceptable however they are put you
know lowering people into acid
containers
dogs snakes
so it seems like somebody who's been
stoned from the minute they were born
until today who claimed to be Muslim
they're sitting in an office somewhere
what should I do now to people that's so
outrageous
you know and they don't care what Islam
says so the point I want to mention here
the biggest
theme
always had from the beginning until
today we want to bring back ruling by
what Allah has revealed
they are the biggest group who
actually destroys what Allah has
revealed never ruled by what Allah has
revealed nothing so they are their
danger now made rasulullah say so many
statements about them
his companions had the opportunity to
kill to to to fight the first hawari
groups and they killed Osman they said
Khalif Khalifa
[Music]
they killed him and then every
generation they come up uh one last
point the Hadith also uh one Muslim
Muslims that these groups will keep
coming in every generation maybe you
didn't hear that but that's why you've
been plagued throughout our history with
this group they keep coming
and the one that's before them may be
completely destroyed the new ones will
say these people were stupid they didn't
know what to do you know with the
smarter ones and they become more
violent
actually
I can't believe there is nothing that
these people which is Haram in Islam
this allowed that they didn't do it's
unbelievable so to attach Islamic State
to it what's wrong with you people
Islamic State Islamic State allowed you
to go to Peaceful Christian communities
they've been living before Muhammad came
and prospered after Muhammad came stayed
alive in their areas until just a few
years back you go and kill them and
steal their women and call them your
slave girls
no they're not
so this is all of these things we're
seeing this is pretty much opposite of
Islam and this is this has nothing to do
with Islam that's that's clear
correct I this is a perfect statement
you just said